[Música]
cuando se cumplieron 100 días de
ofensiva rusa en ucrania las autoridades
de severodonezk informaron que han
retomado el 20 por ciento de la ciudad a
su vez la unión europea aprobó el sexto
paquete de sanciones contra moscú y el
presidente vladimir putin aseguró que no
atacar a los puertos ucranianos que sean
antes mínimos para el paso de cereales
bloqueado desde hace semanas
el movimiento ni una menos nacido en
argentina en 2015 cumplió siete años y
cientos de mujeres salieron a las calles
de buenos aires para exigir el fin de
los feminicidios la violencia machista y
la impunidad
las mujeres reiteraron su petición de
una reforma judicial con perspectiva de
género
en el segundo día de celebraciones por
el jubileo de platino de la reina isabel
segunda en reino unido- la monarca no
asistió el servicio de acción de
gracias' que se celebró en la catedral
de saint paul y el palacio de buckingham
informó que tampoco estará presente en
el hipódromo este sábado para presenciar
la carrera de epson derby
en france 24 estamos de vuelta con las
noticias que marcan las jornadas hoy
valentina torres anchas y es un gusto
acompañarlos iniciamos en ucrania donde
se cumplieron 100 días desde el inicio
de la invasión rusa pese a que las
fuerzas del kremlin continúan su
ofensiva en severodonezk el ejército
ucraniano informó que retomó el control
del 20 por ciento del territorio perdido
en esa ciudad naciones unidas estima que
más de 4.000 personas han perdido la
vida y otras 5 mil han resultado heridas
a causa de los enfrentamientos
a continuación veremos un recuento de lo
que ha sido el conflicto que inició el
24 de febrero el presidente volodymyr
selenski informó que hasta el momento
rusia controla alrededor del 20 por
ciento del territorio ucraniano pero
resaltó que confía en que su país
logrará la victoria además de los
muertos y heridos esta guerra ha dejado
casi 7 millones de refugiados y 8
millones de desplazados internos casi
260 mil deportaciones forzosas hacia
rusia y al menos 13.000 casos en estudio
por posibles crímenes de guerra
entre voces alarmistas y otras más
optimistas el 24 de febrero se cumplió
el peor de los pronósticos en europa
rusia decidió invadir ucrania bajo el
pretexto de desclasificar el país y
proteger a los rusos parlantes como un
premio te ha tomado la decisión de
lanzar una operación militar sus abuelos
y bisabuelos no lucharon defendiendo
nuestra patria para que los neonazis de
hoy se hicieran con el poder de ucrania
los rusos entraron a la nación vecina
por distintos frentes por el norte
noreste desde el donbass y por el sur
desde crimea en manos rusas desde su
ocupación en 2014 junto al pánico entre
los ucranianos y las pérdidas de vidas
humanas las sanciones de occidente no
tardaron en llegar a risoul conchi
estamos decididos a imponer costes
masivos a rusia costes que la aislarán
aún más del sistema financiero
internacional y en nuestras economías
con mis las primeras conversaciones
entre las delegaciones rusas y
ucranianas para negociar el 28 de
febrero no evitaron a la avanzada rusa
como una llamada de auxilio del
presidente ucraniano
demuestren que están con nosotros
demuestren que no nos dejarán demuestren
quiénes son verdaderamente europeos
entonces la vida vencerá a la muerte y
la luz a la oscuridad
con la caída de gerson el 3 de marzo la
primera derrota ucraniana el sufrimiento
solo acababa de empezar las mayores
víctimas hasta el momento los civiles
espero que mi esposa haya muerto rápido
de fast hope is this moment my wife's
pero que en este momento mi esposa está
en el cielo el que todo haya sido
perfecto en su vida en his life
tras otros bombardeos contra civiles
como el del teatro de mariupol uno de
los puntos de inflexión de la guerra se
vivió a principios de abril tras
descubrir decenas de cadáveres en lucha
tirados en las calles a maniatados algo
por lo que la comunidad internacional
empezó a hablar de genocidio
de la verdad del asunto usted vio lo que
pasó en lucha putin es un criminal de
guerra
con ayudas multimillonarias
ucrania consiguió hacer retroceder a los
rusos dejar que la segunda ciudad del
país a mediados de mayo pero no lograron
salvar mariupol que cayó en manos rusas
el 21 de mayo
como sostuvimos diferente
actualmente la avanzada rusa se
concentra en el este y en el horizonte
el fin de la guerra es muy incierto con
una multitudinaria protesta el colectivo
ni una menos conmemora los siete años
desde su fundación en argentina cientos
de mujeres marcharon en buenos aires
para exigir al gobierno que tome medidas
urgentes para enfrentar los feminicidios
la violencia machista y la falta de
igualdad de género con consignas como
vivas y libres nos queremos las mujeres
volvieron a pedir una reforma judicial
con perspectiva de género
lo que nos pasa a ti es que la justicia
es lenta y el patriarcal
y muchas veces las mujeres a pesar de
las muchas renuncias que hacen no son
escuchadas ni son cuidadas
y en general las que mueren mueren
después de haber hecho muchas denuncias
lo cual es muy grave porque significa
que el estado está ausente en venezuela
entró en funcionamiento ven a una
aplicación ofrecida por el gobierno con
la finalidad de acercarse a la
ciudadanía y poder registrar en tiempo
real problemas cotidianos de las
comunidades como las fallas en los
principales servicios públicos a pesar
de que ya cuenta con más de 100.000
descargas desde el pasado mes de marzo
entre los expertos de seguridad digital
crece el temor por el establecimiento de
un mayor control de datos por parte del
gobierno de nicolás maduro más en el
siguiente informe
venezuela da un paso más hacia un
acercamiento digital del gobierno de
nicolás maduro puso en marcha en app una
herramienta tecnológica que funciona
como las redes sociales conocidas pero
que le servirá a las autoridades para
conocer los problemas que afectan a las
comunidades la red social de la
aplicación
para el pueblo y la juventud venezolano
y la aplicación venga
va a ser
va a tener algo llamado la línea 58
que puede ser utilizado por cualquier
ciudadano más allá de las declaraciones
gubernamentales entre los especialistas
de las redes sociales y seguridad
digital crece el temor sobre que la
nueva aplicación incrementa el control
digital por parte del gobierno del
futuro es una herramienta que van a
tratar de utilizar para impulsar una
especie de gobierno digital y lo como
muy entre comillas porque hay que ver
cómo eso se
transforma realmente cómo se están
atendiendo los los reportes las
denuncias que se hagan a través de la
plataforma puesto lo que estáis
apuntando al 2024 1.093 y adelantar las
elecciones ya veremos pero lo que estás
apuntando a las próximas elecciones
presidenciales como un mecanismo también
para ellos poder organizarse los
planteos y un posible incremento en el
control gubernamental a los ciudadanos
cobran fuerza en un país atravesado por
una crisis socioeconómica que de acuerdo
con el observatorio venezolano de
conflictividad social registró 6 mil 560
protestas en el año 2021
en reino unido- de los miembros de la
familia real se reunieron en la iglesia
de sant pau para participar de la
ceremonia de acción de gracias' en el
marco de las celebraciones por el
jubileo de platino de la reina isabel 2ª
una cita a la que la monarca no pudo
asistir debido a molestias de salud el
palacio de buckingham informó que la
reina tampoco asistirá al hipódromo y el
sábado para presenciar la carrera epson
derbi
zumba ceremonia y fiesta la multitud se
reunió en las afueras de la catedral de
sampol el viernes para celebrar el
jubileo de platino de la reina isabel
segunda que cumple el récord de 70 años
en el trono la monarca de 96 años no
participó de servicio por problemas de
movilidad pero siguió el acto a través
de la televisión desde el castillo de
windsor bendita sea necesita descansar
ayer fue un gran día sin embargo la
familia de isabel segunda encabezada por
su hijo y heredero el príncipe carlos
estuvieron en representación de la
monarca en su primera aparición pública
en gran bretaña desde hace dos años
harry y megan fueron recibidos entre
aplausos y también abucheos
me encanta un megane y harri creo que
son una pareja brillante se aman eso es
lo principal y la verdad es que me
sorprendió que la mayoría de la gente
abucheara no entiendo por qué
bueno siento decir que no soy fan de
harry y megan creo que son muy muy muy
respetuosos con la reina amo la reina y
creo que deberían ser más solidarios con
ella pero en un reflejo público de la
creciente presión sobre su liderazgo el
primer ministro boris johnson fue
recibido con un coro unánime de rechazo
la comitiva tomó asiento entre los dos
mil fieles y comenzó la misa
[Música]
en su majestad lamentamos que no esté
aquí con nosotros esta mañana pero nos
alegramos de que siga en el cargo y nos
alegramos de que aún haya más por venir
así que gracias por seguir adelante
y a pesar de que las celebraciones
continuarán durante todo el fin de
semana el palacio de buckingham ha
confirmado que la reina también se
perderá la carrera de caballos del derby
de epsom así como un concierto de música
pop en su honor el sábado
así llegamos al final del informativo
pero quédense con nosotros que volvemos
en breve
[Música]